because thanks to extinction rebellion
Greta thumb burg and David Attenborough
and my others many of us are waking up
to the scale of the climate emergency
facing us the UN Intergovernmental Panel
on Climate Change says we have just 12
years to avert a catastrophe affecting
hundreds and millions of people changing
how we shop and eat is good but it
doesn't go far enough or fast enough and
solutions to the climate emergency won't
work if we end up passing on costs to
people least able to afford it
that's why we need to see bold state-led
proposals on both sides of the Atlantic
we need structural change not surface
change to transform the economy rewiring
it towards renewables and away from
polluting energy sources but a green
revolution has to be a fair one so it's
about cheaper energy and better jobs as
well as cleaner air and water we don't
have the time or the luxury of tinkering
at the edges or waiting for the market
to sort it out only large-scale state
intervention can effectively tackle our
climate crisis
[Music]
welcome and anyway she's perfectly
capable of handling it you've heard of
energy wind haven't you this was this
was in 2011 Angela Merkel and the German
government announced that were going to
look away from nuclear energy after the
tsunami in Japan where we're at and you
could have packed this damage and then
we're going to turn to renewables and it
was the biggest single political project
since reunification in Germany
and seven years later and a hundred and
sixty billion euros later
it's an unmitigated disaster in that
time there has been one day where
whether it was sunny and the wind was
right
they managed to produce 56 gigawatts of
energy which power this this the fourth
industrialized biggest nation in the
world a power defect but that's for one
day only and now the German people are
open arms because they're saying it's
too expensive it's chaotic it's not
working no one can do it properly most
of Germany's electricity is still is
still powered by burning coal and I just
think if a country as efficient is
Germany can't make this I don't think I
don't think have to go the german route
I personally I was I was so inspired by
extinction rebellion I know they were
inconvenience but I was inspired by them
because it made consciousness I think we
do need to take drastic action and the
reason that we've each take we address
reaction I think we can subscribe to
even if I think you're a say some people
might be climate change skeptics
skeptics but I think we can still
subscribe to the need to take
drastic action because of air pollution
and its effect on our children for
example right now you don't have to be a
climate scientist to understand that our
children are breathing in particles
that's making it difficult for their
health and their developing asthmatic
systems or other for symptoms sorry or
other forms of illnesses as a result of
our polluted air which sits about here
which is the height of a child so I
think we have to take drastic action and
one of the things I think the government
is to do very very quickly is create the
ability to charge electric cars all over
the country because currently you buy
those electric cars and there's no way
to charge them so you can't point we all
take me wait you're talking about we're
doing nothing we are taking action we
are
Brina this country is only responsible
for 1.1 percent of carbon and last year
we would you stop in emissions because
we better correct the record let's take
a look at I want to share with you all
the share of annual carbon dioxide
emissions for 2016 is slightly
overstated it there at our China's 29.1%
United States 15 point to India 7 UK 1.1
Kirsty our world of data global carbon
projection so we're 1.1 China we're not
on a level playing field are we I'm
enjoying it here to know you because
clearly you are so minded that the state
can solve everything right whether it's
the fourth poor folk in scan thought
whether its global emissions this is a
government's can't even get railways
built the idea that they could do this
is absolutely sure we were trying to do
more yes should we fly less properly yes
should we have reusable bags I'm all for
that charges when you look can I just
respond to that point directly because I
know when we talk about nationalization
and state ownership I know that for
certain people there's a heart back to
you know incompetent bad old days when
the state was running things three-day
week rubbish on the streets right but
what we're talking about now is
something that is much more modern it's
decentralized its municipal the example
that people are looking to is Denmark
actually where these things are very
vocalize their very community led when
power alone accounts for 42% of
Denmark's energy in 2015 the way that
you the reason that you reach the reason
that you localize it is because regions
know best what's right what's right for
them so it might be it might be marine
turbines in the murphy or it might be
solar power i think i totally see where
you're coming from but i think this
issue is actually too big to rely solely
on government i think we need a private
public park and so really what i'd be
much more interested in is the
government incentivizing the private
sector to come up with solutions and
also using our government facilities for
research to actually do the R&D and then
invest in the private sector to actually
implement this stuff because we know
with the government is the
implementation that you can i also add
something to the mix i think we should
be looking at nuclear well yeah watch
the documentary Pandora's secret okay so
it's quite good so what I would say
about the reason that this needs to be
state lead is purely number one it's the
scale of a problem and number two we
need to make sure it's fair so when we
look at just as an example kind of look
at the example the example of the late
Labor's just announced this policy to
put solar panels in a million a million
and three quarter of a million homes so
the first million will be free they will
be social housing let's look at what we
get for about nuclear let's just look at
what we get from that and then we can go
back to you if we do that we get each
household saving 117 pounds a year we we
have been usually I mean you should but
this is how this is how people live this
solar panels I think I understand it to
be the case I might be wrong but
actually the environmental cost of
making those tanks it does more damage
the environment
renewable energy place that does you
come you are best in it to begin with it
like getting doubled lazy panelists you
know the ones with the expensive ones
and they want to keep arriving they see
you insist and today since produces
efficient and it's 21 percent efficiency
rate it's very very cheap very no damage
to air quality expensive to build but
cheap to run why not I'm not saying we
should exclude or include any of these
things and to your point June and I
think what we're looking at when things
like energy is that the state owns the
National Grid so it's responsible for
distribution and supply anything is
because people fear nuclear because of
the consequences of a disaster but it's
a bit like an aeroplane it's safer to
fly it sorry I know that's not good for
environment but just on a side note it's
safer to fly than it is to drive cars
but people are more scared of flying
because of the consequences of crash
will kill everyone on board and
nuclear's like that it's very in the
with the state technology as it is today
it's very unlikely to have another in
fact studies show that even the worst
possible accident in nuclear plant is
less destructive than other major enough
of that hot air watching the page on Sky
News up next a lesson for the panel in
fairness
[Music]